تتم عمليه اخراج مالك ماللندي 52 عاما حي
يرزق بعد سبعه ايام من تواجده وسط الركاب
هو الان هنا تماما امامي سيطروا عمليا
اسعافه
بالسروم
والمياه القليله ثم
تتم عمليه نقله بهذه الاسعافيه الى المشفى
القريبه بعد تقدير حالته الصحيه سبعه ايام
قضاها تحت هذا الركاب هذا الركام جميع
الالات الثقيله وقفت عليه يعني تقريبا كنا
نعمل على اخراج جدد وليس احياء لكن قضاء
الله وقدره قبل ساعه او ساعتين الى الان
تبين ان هناك شخص حي
بالمناداه باني موجود داخل هذا الركام نصف
جسدي يعني تحت الانقاض وجسد العلوي النصف
العلوي
جيد
وهو جيد ادلانا على منطقته بالتحديد
واستطعنا يعني
فرق الانقاذ المختصه لكون نحن لا نعلم
يعني الطرق الحقيقيه والاساسيه خوفا على
حياه الموجودين داخل الركام هذا المبنى
تحديدا طلع او خرج منه العشرات من القتلى
لكن هناك ايضا عدد كبير من الناجين كان
اخرهم صباح عندما
تم اخراج طفله وشاب اثناء عمليه نفس هذه
العمليه نتمنى من الله ان لا تتك